hi welcome back to another gadget lab
show i'm michael colori i'm john
phillips
this week we attended the google i o
conference it's a big show for
developers a lot of huge announcements
we're going to rip through the two
biggest ones right now
which are
the new tablet which comes with jelly
bean on it all sorts of enhancements and
the nexus q
which is the sort of home media
enjoyment device that google announced
this week
um why don't we go through jelly bean
first right so uh this well this is
nexus 7 running jelly bean the new os
android 4.1 comes in black and white
right right now i have the maps app up
and so it has 3d maps simple matter of
uh
you know just sort of gliding through
the os moving back moving forward so
basically it gives you a three-quarter
iso isometric view of of your city so
that's one big feature there's very cool
if you're by the way if you're looking
for um like if you're if you're looking
for directions and all of a sudden you
go into 3d view you can end up like
zooming around the neighborhood and get
really distracted and waste time
right right uh another big thing it's
sort of trying to be very amazon kindle
firish and so you go to the google play
store
and you get these direct links to movies
and books
tv shows now and they're really trying
to push
media purchasing as well so that's a big
part of it and then there's a magazine
store right
now what's the cards thing i always call
it cards but what is it again oh it's
called google now
and basically you access it from any
jelly bean touch screen device by
starting at the bottom of the screen and
swiping up as quickly as possible and
then you get this really nice display of
information that's relevant to you right
now based on location based on your own
data that's stored on the device and
based on your most recent search history
so let's say i'm an oakland a's fan and
i'm always asking about
you know what are the oakland day scores
today i'm always searching reading news
about the oakland days it's going to
show me a little card at the top of of
google now whenever i swipe up i'll see
if there's a game going on i'll see the
scores if a game just ended i'll see
what the box score is plus a link to
read more about the game it's always
going to show me whether
uh if i commute a lot and it knows my
work address and knows my home address
and i tell it to google now will show me
the um traffic information for my
commute or if i take the bus so it'll
show me when my next bus arrives so it's
totally customizable it learns a lot on
its own but from what i found just from
a day or so playing with it is that it
benefits a lot from
information that you put into it as well
right very cool very slick feature
it's enhanced by voice search pizza
all right i understood that one pretty
clearly
and it's showing me let's see there's
some round table coupons and the paid
search results at the top then there's a
giant map with a bunch of pins on it
with a bunch of pizza locations in my
neighborhood yelp reviews i can click on
the map
it'll open up maps on the tablet and
then i can pinch and zoom in on where
i'm having my slice right so it's a
pretty intuitive system it's not as
intuitive or as effective as siri but
it's getting closer and it really shows
that google is hyper aware that people
want voice control and they want you
know sort of graphical representations
as a result of these voice searches too
yeah yeah now what you were saying about
um the sort of amazonish storefront
right and we should note that this
tablet costs 200. right very inexpensive
and that is the same price as
the kindle fire same price as kindle
fire and it's got much better hardware
specs so it's got a 1280 by 800 screen
it's got a
quad core cpu it so it's much faster
than the kindle fire which we really
took to task
november of last year and it'll ship
with uh ice cream sandwich and then
it'll get jelly beans in july right
right
uh and also it's tied into this it's
tied into that so where this is 200 this
is 300
and a lot of people are questioning well
what is this and why does it cost so
much so this is the nexus queue it's a
it's an audio streamer essentially this
is a video streamer and video it's a
media stream it's a media streamer this
little ball
sucks down digital content from the
cloud you control it with your android
device and if we had it connected up to
you know its full complement of of stuff
it would be connected to speakers and an
hd tv
so essentially it plays google music and
youtube and movies you rent from google
play and uh when you play audio it has
this visualizer so as i move the volume
control
there it goes back to blue and then in a
second it should pop back to the
visualizer now these leds
those are leds so i actually visited the
factory where these are made you could
check it out online and i talked to the
engineers and the and the industrial
designers who built it
there are 32 leds 32 rgb leds around the
perimeter and then they use sort of like
this this light um this light pipe that
diffuses it all the leds and makes it
this continuous band so it can do any
color in the rainbow right it can dance
around at any speed any color in the
rainbow and we we heard it you're more
of an audiophile than i am and you you
actually thought it sounded pretty good
it does sound pretty good now granted
it's a 25 watt solid-state class d amp
in here and it's bolted onto the bottom
of what is basically a android phone um
and it sounds pretty good it sounds as
good as the other 20 watt 25 watt class
d amps you can buy out there on the
market um the price is a little bit
inflated because it obviously has a
beautiful design it's made in the united
states that makes it a little bit more
expensive
the factory is local here in california
and it has a um it has the ability to
hook it up to some really nice speakers
it takes banana plug jacks so what we
heard was the 300 amp hooked up to a set
of 400 speakers using google's 50 cables
so for an outlay of 750
you have an audio device that sounds
awesome and only plays music that is
stored in google music
or is stored right right on your actual
device currently it doesn't work with
rdo or spotify or any other amps and you
know so it's a very niche product and
that's sort of the early hands-ons and
my own criticism of it is that you know
it for what it does it does very well
but
is what it does enough for 300 bucks
right and that is a question that we
will answer when we review it
and you can read the full product review
on meyer.com and you can also read about
a dozen or so stories that we wrote
while we were at google i o
over the last week and
included in that package is john's
amazing feature about the development of
the nexus q so sink or swim
it's still a pretty awesome product it's
cool touch it's cool look at it says a
lot about what google's trying to do and
we'll find out who's going to buy it
when it goes on sale in july
that's it for this week and we'll see
you next time from the gadget lab